you guys seem to really like my review
of fracture and I want to do a few more
overlooked reviews as often as I can
wherever I come across a movie that I
think is just great that just didn't get
the attention it deserved that really is
underrated I want to talk with you guys
about it and today I'm going to be
talking about brick I really screwed up
huh
brick what I didn't know was bad but did
the pins on it now you gotta help me
slow down this isn't good
no brick stars Joseph gordon-levitt and
it's a film that he made before he was
getting big he was really in that
transitional phase between child star
and adult actor he was trying to get out
of that and this is one of the first
movies that displayed the true talent he
really has this movie is a 100%
underrated gem I loved literally
everything about this movie it was a
powerhouse film of independent directing
and it was just a great way for a
director to explode onto the scene this
guy Ryan Johnson he wrote and directed
this film let me tell you what it's
about Joseph gordon-levitt hears that an
old girlfriend of his has been in
trouble and then she turns up dead so he
decides to investigate what was going on
with her her past life thinks she was in
is a film noir detective story set in
high school now you would think these
people are pretty young I don't know if
I can buy that they're out there being
detectives and almost getting killed and
I felt that way at first until the film
started poking fun at that very thing
and I love that like they would had this
really intense scene and then they would
cut to the kids in the kitchen and their
mom was like bringing them a glass of
milk and a cookie or something and it's
just it was great how they poked fun at
the fact that they were young
you're coming into a certain situation
twisted I'm looking for Emily he left
her yeah I did you better be sure you
know complicated everyone's got their
thing this movie has an extremely
intricate and complex plot and if you
pay attention very closely you'll be
able to follow it this movie is
spellbinding it's mesmerizing I loved
every second of this movie this film is
so set on displaying a tone a perfect
tone of film noir ecstasy you guys may
know that one of my favorite animes is
Cowboy Bebop
this film is heavily inspired by that
anime the director himself said that
while he was making this movie he was
very inspired by cowboy bebop and you
can see it in every frame just look at
Joseph gordon-levitt's character he
looks so much like spike the lead
character of Cowboy Bebop
even walks like him with his back
hunched over his hands in his pocket
the hair is the same the way they focus
on the boots quite often it's just so
reminiscent of the same film noir style
that Cowboy Bebop had which is one of
the reasons why I love this movie so
much because that style is just so
brilliant to me
I can see the bottom whatever this is
what do you want justice it's too hot
you got discipline issue with me right
now you offer suspend me gordon-levitt
is magnetic in each scene that he's in
in this movie I really think that Joseph
gordon-levitt has been worthy of an
Oscar in at least three films already I
would say that he was good enough for
one in this film the lookout and
definitely 50/50 I cannot wait till that
guy gets nominated for an Oscar because
he is freakin brilliant the way this
movie unfolds its plot the way it's told
the script the acting just the entire
feel of this movie is a film fans dream
if you have not seen brick I implore you
please watch brick I thought about this
for a long time I haven't rated a movie
that I only saw once this rating in a
very long time but I'm going to give
brick and a plus I see that you're
trying to help and I don't know anybody
I would do that for me you are dangerous
I stood out - no put her on the spot put
her in front of the gun there's not much
chance it coming out clean I have no
problems with this movie whatsoever and
I'm positive that I'm going to watch
this movie many times in the future if
you have not seen brick please check it
out if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my
eyes